Ariana Grande and Pete Davidson may have
called it quits but now a source tells
ET the two still have mad love for each
other quote they are remaining positive
and looking forward to a future together
where they may be best friends and still
haven't ruled out the possibility of one
day making their relationship work the
source adds that the former couple are
still in communication in fact an eye
witness tells ET that the singer was
backstage with Pete on Saturday night at
Saturday Night Live and was affectionate
with him
ariana was set to perform at a charity
event in LA on Saturday but pulled out
last minute her manager Scooter Braun
broke the news to the crowd you saw your
invite somewhat I'm very close to was
supposed to come sing for you today and
because of things that she's going
through she couldn't be here today and
while I was frustrated being the manager
my wife being who she always is just
looked at me and she goes she needs this
time if people are coming to see her
sing and not building to the Cancer
Foundation I don't want them there
anyway Ariana and Pete got engaged in
June after just weeks of dating and just
be crying like out of happiness
literally lately I was on FaceTime last
night crying you're like are you okay
you know like yeah does Frankie grande
approve of Pete is the question listen
my sister is super happy so I proved you
know you know as long as as long as
she's happy then I approve but the
engaged bliss took a hit when Ariana's
ex-boyfriend Mac Miller died suddenly in
September a source at the time told et
Pete was a quote huge support to the pop
star as she coped with a rappers
shocking death now a source tells et
Pete and Ariana have quote a very
special connection
partly because Pete has been there for
Ariana during a painful time in her life
she will forever and always be grateful
to Pete
and it was their busy schedules that
ultimately led to their breakup they
have so much going on in their careers
that it made it close to impossible to
spend any time together
also they felt constantly under a
microscope they felt that they literally
had no privacy and it really took a toll
on their relationship the source added
quote Pete is still so in love with her
he wanted his whole world to revolve
around her but she was emotionally
unavailable Pete had to give her that
space out of love but the source says
the two aren't permanently closing the
door on their love they love and trust
each other so much and want to keep the
option open for a future together
[Music]
[Applause]